you
julia bolds well I grew up in Madison
Wisconsin and one of the things about
Madison is a it's about as stable as it
can possibly be here in the United
States but one of the things about
Madison is that international tends to
be Iowa and when I decided that I was
interested in practicing internationally
I ended up by having to move away from
Madison to go to one of the various
coasts but what Madison gave me is a
great grounding and a stability that
allows me to have the confidence to move
on to other parts of the world
my family was a great influence my
mother and father were involved with
lots of activities volunteer activities
in the community as were my grandparents
and they really showed me that serving
the community was an extremely important
value
I had many ambitions I first thought I
would become a doctor and in fact I
applied to medical school I subsequently
have been working as a lawyer and here i
am serving as almost a public speaker
and an advocate for kids
you